hey man merry christmas man i just
wanted to welcome you
welcome you aboard just a little
something wow you didn't have to do that
yeah well you know
yeah but i think you're just uh i didn't
get you anything for
christmas but oh well you know hey next
year okay with amazon
thank you so much
okay books yeah that's crappy it's been
shapiro's book
i've read it um multiple times but thank
you for that
yeah no just in case so we had him we
had a couple of just lying around back
there so i'll be honest i didn't
oh just lying around yeah yeah okay
and andrew clavin so yeah
thank you for this so much yeah it's a
great i'm i'm really excited about
what ed your your book's not yeah well
no that's actually kind of it because i
figured you know
i could give you those two and then
probably to complete the trio you're
going to want to buy my book
on amazon for about 9.99 you give me an
invitation to buy you
yeah just to so that you know that way
you have all three i figured get you
started
so first two so anyway merry christmas
thank you thank you so much
[Music]
okay another gift i was very excited by
gifts that's what this one is
this is from the state of new jersey
which i've not had kind things to say
about new jersey
um there's nothing wrong with new jersey
it's just
there's nothing good about it whatsoever
so they seem to have
given me a box of uh
of their trash which is
what new jersey is known for
at least it doesn't matter there are no
needles that are pricking me it doesn't
smell so i
you know that's that's good at least um
that's a step up they gave me their
highest quality track
for new jersey and uh i think that's all
that oh
no here we go we've got
post-it notes with
feminist slogans why yes i am
overqualified
cause that's exactly what a feminist
needs is to have a post-it note that
just
feeds her ego every single day when she
looks at it
i can't say i'm a big fan of this one
either
that's new jersey's fault
[Music]
okay we got another gift here uh this
one from a fan
in the uk apparently i have
at least one fan in the uk i've got one
fan there i've got two or three fans
here
that makes three or four total um
it's a slow brew
sloth tea infuser
i don't even know what that is okay so
it's just a sloth well here's the note
says greetings from across the pond you
recently reviewed chelsea handler's
stand-up comedy
in which she called slow people koalas i
think she meant to call them sloths
[Music]
enjoy this tea infuser as a reminder of
your listeners in the uk
well my listeners in the uk suck it
would seem apparent
striking out again on christmas
matt hey hey so
i know it's been a little rocky with the
christmas presents this year yeah it has
been
and i just wanted to kind of make up for
it so i figured i'm your producer i know
you're better than most here you guys
are too generous you didn't
i mean you didn't have to do that again
i didn't get you anything either so i'm
starting to feel awkward about that but
uh thank you for uh
[Music]
thank you for this oh it's a uh
corkscrew like a fish right because
you're into fishing so i figured that'd
be the best thing you know
it's related to what you like it's
useful it's a tool
yeah thank you so much this is really
great i actually needed
i needed one of these for uh my for my
house
i didn't have i only had i only had a
couple i needed an extra one so thanks
so much
cool man thank you all right yeah merry
christmas merry christmas
thanks
it's not even the good kind of corkscrew
because this this is the kind
you try to unscrew wine and then you try
you pull it out and the wine goes all
over the place it's not you know the
ones where you
you it's like a levee system this is not
even a core screw that
i've got three core screws at the house
that are work better than this
so yeah it's shaped like a fish but i've
got one of the houses shaped like a
moose already
i can't even get a good course girl
around here
all right another another day of
christmas for me great
another great gift we'll see we'll see
we'll see what this one's about
it's an interesting shape at least
it could be jewelry maybe not that i
really wear jewelry
[Applause]
box
[Music]
so christmas ornaments
[Music]
well it's the box is great this is a
great i could use this box for a lot of
different things
um it's a really beautiful
well-made box i like the box
all right um maybe this will be more
successful so i've got a gift here from
one of the feminist
comedians that i've been having a lot of
fun making fun of won't say names but
she says that this
is uh would be the cure to my toxic
masculinity
it's because of my toxic masculinity
that i don't find feminist comedians
funny so maybe this is
this will do it we'll see
all right
it's very feminine wrapping paper
feminist icon cross stitch
30 daring designs to celebrate
strong women i don't even know what
cross stitch is
um but i still i still feel my toxic
masculinity
raging inside me and i have the ultimate
defense
against any attempts to get rid of my
toxic masculinity which is
the beard
hey i just wanted to say merry christmas
i know how hard he worked
this year and i thought that you
deserved a charinga flip flop summer
beach sandal shower slippers non-slip
funny crazy
shoes pear i think that you will enjoy
them i mean
i'll be honest you're really really
difficult to shop for so i think that
you'll enjoy these more than any person
that i know
who are these four again who are we
talking all right
[Music]
i feel a lot of pressure uh now because
this is actually a gift
from my wife uh she
has decided to step in and
uh and and give a gift as well um
but we'll see it's a gift i have to like
have to
[Music]
stfu i'm reading now the kids tell me
that stands for
a naughty word so i look that i like so
telling people to shut up and leave me
alone while i'm reading
that i kind of like and it's a scented
candle
[Music]
i don't know what that's supposed to be
it spells smells like a
[Music]
like an explosion of shampoo
and potpourri and perfume
but it's from my wife so i i really like
it
a lot
hey dude uh they told me i have to give
a big gift this year
oh thank you yeah so much
oh it's a whiskey
not a very big one
[Applause]
it's not enough to really get the job
done is it he's got whole gallons of
whiskey back there but this is what i
did so
great that's how valued i am around here
i guess
[Applause]
all right we've got another one ah
this is from jasper
[Music]
you got me a gift i don't know how a dog
would wrap a gift without
possible thumbs but um all right i'll
see what buy dog got me
bob ross chia pet
i guess because you know he's the office
pet he wants me to have a pet
it's supposed to be cute i guess it's
awful
this is why i hate dogs they're annoying
they slobber
and they don't even know how to get good
gifts
so it's been uh 10 days of of gifts 10
or 11 days been 10 days of gifts
and they've all been just utterly hard
and this is why
you know i i think we need to get rid of
gift giving
in general and i i just don't i i think
in the end you know
by by the time of our death it's uh at
best you broke it even because you spent
a lot of money on gifts you've gotten
gifts you don't like most of them
it's awkward as you could tell it's just
an awkward thing to receive gifts you
don't like puts a lot of pressure on
it's pressure on the person to buy the
gifts is pressure when you receive it
it's just a negative experience all
around buying gifts
uh and i think if we just got rid of
gift giving entirely
then what are holidays holidays are just
eating and drinking and they don't have
to worry about giving gifts
but um i wanted to prove at least that
i think a better job could be done than
what's been done so far for me with
gifts
so i went on amazon and i purchased this
for myself i just kind of
i didn't even look at what it was i just
got thrown a dart i just scrolled
randomly
i hit buy now i didn't even look at what
it was i had amazon gift wrap it
they didn't do a great job at gift
wrapping i was expecting a better job
but this is what they did for me
um and uh let's see what it is i mean
this has to be better at least than what
i've gotten so far
it's not just that i'm a miserable
person but i don't like all the gifts
and that's part of it but
also the gifts have been pretty bad i
think we can all be honest about that
so what do we end up with here
well i feel like this was rigged this
was rigged against me because there's no
way
that that could have worked out as
perfectly as that
that is our notorious rbg mesa rest in
peace
the t-shirt uh it doesn't even i don't
even think this size fits me not that i
would wear it but uh
no actually it's a large okay so i have
no excuse not to wear it but
uh you know i i feel like this this
doesn't make any sense i i choose
randomly i end up with an rbg
i mean are these that popular that they
would just be up on amazon when you
scroll randomly i don't know
maybe this was her dying wish this was
her dying wish that i
wear this shirt but unfortunately that
dying wish will also not be
[Music]
heated
man hey sean all right
this is it man tried every gift i can
think of you're impossible to shop for
so merry christmas
i appreciate it i guess thank you
i thought all the gifts suck
12 days of christmas
number 12.
[Music]
you